there is a new documentary app
from espn
and this is a documentary on
one of the worst
hate crimes in american history
this is
a documentary about a hate crime almost
as bad
and almost as real
as the attack on jesse smallett in
downtown chicago you remember when
the white supremacist homophobic gay
nigerian man attacked jessie
because chicago is mega country
well this this was not quite as serious
as that but it was it was close this was
the attack
on bubba wallace bubba wallace is
apparently a nascar driver it took place
at the talladega speedway and they found
a noose
hanging in the garage i bet you know we
didn't see it but i bet there were
burning crosses everywhere i bet there's
probably a clan rally happening right
outside the garage right is that what
happened
well if you listen to the trailer for
this documentary that's probably the
conclusion you would draw
the most
incredible
non-competitive moment in sports i'd
ever seen
that moment i could feel the weight of
that moment and and i think we all did
as we were walking
when i
get out of the car
i look back
and i was like holy sh it's a whole
garage the whole garage
that's when i lost it
in the midst of all the turmoil
that was going on in the world
with the black and white the hatred and
everything that was going on
the entire nascar family
rallied behind my son
[Music]
wow just brings a tear to your eye for
how
much the united states has completely
lost its mind
here is the story being told by that
trailer
white supremacy
is pervasive
black men can barely walk out of their
homes without being chased down that's
what lebron james said
and this black
nascar driver found a noose
hanging in his stall from the hate crime
but
but
the the
drivers from nasa the whole nascar
family
they decided to overcome their racism
which is so
so pervasive and they stood up and they
said no we don't want to
attack you bubba we support you and we
oppose all those racists and white
supremacists and bubba was so
overwhelmed because because the default
mode in america now is for all these
white supremacists to just lynch black
guys left and right that's what's going
on constantly and amid all the turmoil
and the hatred of the blacks and the
whites
finally
finally there was a moment of racial
unity
none of that happened it was just a tie
to pull the door down
it wasn't a noose it was a little tie to
pull the door down none of it it had
been there for months and months
it had nothing to do with bubba wallace
it was just a little
tie
yeah it was not surprising
that all these nascar people came out to
support bubba wallace
over this fictional event because there
aren't any white supremacists or
klansmen there it's just it's not real
it's not real none of this is real
there's no the racial the only racial
turmoil in recent years was when blm
burned the country down last year and it
wasn't white supremacists doing it it
was blm and antifa at the encouragement
of leftist politicians very prominent
ones including the current president and
vice president of the united states
and to be as fair as i can to blm
i'm not talking about the radicals and
the real leaders and the really vicious
people i'm talking about the regular old
idiots who just go along with it
they did it in no small part because of
the lie being perpetrated by these
people by espn and by the liberal
establishment that there's this
pervasive problem of white supremacy and
that nooses are being left around every
black eyes house
none of which is happening it's just all
fake it's all completely fake
it's not a documentary
it is
a fable it is a legend
being told it is a lie being told as the
truth
by
propagandists
it is a mass psychosis that we are
watching go on
it is it is a kind of religious ecstasy
that you're seeing happen on that track
at nascar and in the movie and the
people being moved to tears because
finally there's a solution to this
problem that doesn't exist
and and you know what i don't even
really blame them
one i don't blame the people who are
under the spell of the media the media
are very very powerful
but i don't even blame the people who
are engaging in these performances
these performances are religious
liturgies when you go out
and you hold hands and you
sing about the racial unity or frankly
even when you go out and loot and burn
like blm did it is a kind of religious
liturgy and man is a religious being
okay and we need some kind of religion
because we know that we're not quite at
home in this world
we it's kind of weird that we didn't
create ourselves we just came into being
we know that there are things like
beauty and truth and right and wrong and
goodness and morality and joy and we
can't make sense of it because those
aren't physical things but we see the
physical world and so we know that there
is a spiritual and metaphysical world
but there's no satisfaction to those
longings in a world that tells you that
that religion is bogus and christianity
is fake but we still have that desire
and so we fall into new religions weird
kooky racial religions neo-pagan
religions that are divorced from reality
such as
the racial narratives going on
in our country right now
i'm so glad you liked that clip now if
you want to get all the clips and all
the shows and all the episodes you've
got to
ring the bell and subscribe that way
you'll get notifications and by the way
if you really want to guarantee you get
notifications for the whole show head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe
maybe leave a five star review if you
like it we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]